[Music]
kylie is with us in houston texas hey
kylie how are you
i'm good hi jay nice to talk to you you
too what's up
so my my husband and i are under
contract for a house but we close on in
two weeks and he got a job offer in
colorado
that we are really considering taking
but we're under contract and we
don't know if we should just
walk away from the house and lose the
money we put into it so far which isn't
that much
or if we should because we won't be
moving out there until the summer anyway
so i don't know if we should stay and
then try and resell the house
because that's what you know a lot of
people are telling us to do with the
market
but it seems like a lot of work to me
and like a risk and i'm just not sure
what to do it's a lot of work and it's a
risk but you have your you've given your
word
what do you mean
i mean you promised these people on
paper you were going to buy their house
okay well a realtor said we could walk i
don't give a crap what your realtor said
okay well that's fine i mean
you do what you want to do but if i if i
told these people i was going to buy
their house i'd buy their house
i want the house
i mean well you're not staying there
you're not staying there if you're going
to colorado but my point is is that you
have a moral obligation to honor a
contract that you signed giving your
word to buy a house
it's not those poor people's fault that
you took a job afterwards
so you need to consider whether you take
that job as a part of that situation but
i think you should close on the house
because you said you would
now then can you resell it make money i
sure hope so
if you're going to colorado and i would
actually put that in as a stipulation as
a part of taking the job with a new
employer that they buy your house that
you just bought yeah if you can't sell
it for a profit within x period of time
or maybe you're not supposed to take
this job but i can tell you this you're
not going to call this show and me tell
you to break your word
i'm curious about the decision-making
process if there was a job offer some
interviews happening here while the
house is happening house has been under
contract for a long time it closes in
two weeks
yeah and then the job offer came out of
nowhere some dub on linkedin called him
and he just got the hot foot
and uh so no i mean you gave your word
can you keep your word
that was old-fashioned dude look at that
old-fashioned wow grandpa said you shook
your hand and you meant it i just like
the word dupe i think we need to bring
that back yeah well linkedin dude in
particular
this is the ramsay show